I think the Coalition has done a good
job you know I just I feel like there's
a little bit of that je ne sais quoi
that little Special Sauce that's just
kind of been missing the last couple
months and I've been I've been very very
obvious and open about the fact that I'd
be happy to that's about to say if they
watch it awesome is it the heart that
you feel that is out of it because I
felt in the first three
had that horror but also had heart right
what do you think is missing
ah
I don't know you know honestly maybe me
what's up the thing is this this goes
back to
um again this is another person in
Hollywood who's had a rough patch as of
late Josh Joss Whedon right yes right
um I'm a huge Buffy fan yeah I just you
know my wife looks just like Sarah
Michelle Geller because I had the
biggest crush on the Lakewood for so
long and then I'm like oh okay this is
all making sense
you know when I was I was talking to
Jocelyn what comic